thing that mentioned, the
fourth out of ten. Tonight
inshallah, to Allah will be
discussing the fifth thing and
that is as says, the
says, the fifth thing that will
open a person's heart.
[Silence]
his heart to Islam. This is a
verse that is taken to mean by
many people who read it. To
mean that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala will open open his heart
to accept Islam. Meaning to
transition from being a non
Muslim and to being a Muslim.
That's correct. but it's also
the different aspects of Islam.
Because a person may become
Muslim but they will bring some
baggage with them. Into Islam.
Correct? So a person will bring
baggage with with them into
Islam. A person will bring
baggage with him into Islam.
old habits, old vices, old
whatever. Right? And so
whoever, whomever Allah desires
to guide, he will open his
heart to Islam. Holistically
and specific parts of Islam.
Right? We have this text. The
next text is the narration of
in Bukhari. Whoever Allah
desires good for, he will. He
will give him understanding of
the religion. Number three, the
third text is also collected by
on the authority of whomever
Allah desires good for, he will
tribulate and test and give
hardship to in this life, okay?
So, three things. If Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala wishes to
guide a person to Islam, he
will open his heart. What will
open his heart Two main things.
Number one, he will make him
humble. And that is with tests
and tribulations. Number two,
he will make him understanding.
And that is with learning what
aspects of the religion concern
him. statement of the prophet
[Silence]
what this narration means is
that whomever Allah desires
good for, he will teach him
enough of his religion by which
he will be able to worship him
adequately and reach him based
on his circumstances and based
on who he is destined to be.
So, if he is somebody who is a
worker, he will teach him of
his religion. the etiquettes
of employment. If he is
somebody who is a a sales you
will teach him and he will
guide him to learn and
understand the regulations of
sales transactions. So, that is
money will remain pure etcetera
and so, These narrations here
and this verse, these are, this
articulates to us that humility
and knowledge are the key to
guidance, humility, and
knowledge that a person is
humble to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. Because knowledge will
never be taken by somebody who
is arrogant. A person who is
arrogant may learn facts. But
they will never learn
knowledge. Knowledge is what is
in the and affects thee and
affects a person's actions and
so, a person who is arrogant,
this person will never, will
never learn. A good example of
that are some of the followers
of Musa Alaihi Salam. They were
scholars. They learned, right?
And where they were ended up
being some of the greatest
hypocrites and enemies to the
prophets that ever existed. To
the point that they even kill
prophets, right? To the point
that they would even
consistently kill prophets
every time a prophet would
appear with that which they did
not they would kill him.
Zacharia being one of them,
right? However, and they
attempted to kill However,
these people were not people of
knowledge. They were people of
information. They had
information. They had facts but
knowledge in the sense of what
the Quran refers to as
knowledge. No, they did not
have this. It did not reach
their heart. It did not
illuminate their heart. What is
he then the
about these people of
information that what is sent
down to you from your lord will
only increase them in? In their
transgression and in their
disbelief. Why? Because they're
arrogant. Arrogance is
something that will bar you
from learning. And as was
reported that Abdul Aziz
said that just as the valley
and the lowest parts of the
earth collect the most water.
Likewise the most humble of
students will collect the most
knowledge right? The least
amount of knowledge is found,
the least amount of water is
found where on the top of a
mountain. The further down that
mountain you go and the more
you venture into its valley,
the more water you will find.
That's where the water settles.
It settles at the lowest point
of the earth and so, the more a
person humbles himself and bows
himself to Allah, the more
Allah Allah will teach him.
More a person Allah will teach
him. And this is the meaning of
the statement of the prophet
Whoever humbles himself to
Allah, Allah will raise him.
But does that mean he will
raise him? He will teach him,
grant him action, and then
raise his levels. Right?
Because there are reason for
Allah raising people, correct?
And there are reasons for Allah
lowering people. There are
reasons for people entering
paradise and there are reasons
for people entering hell. There
are reasons for people being
guided and there are reasons
for people being misguided,
correct? We understand this
from the Quran. And so, when
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, when
the prophet says, Whoever
humbles himself to Allah, Allah
will raise him. This means that
Allah will teach him grant him
success to implement what he
has taught him. Henceforth,
raising him in levels. and so,
knowledge is a critical point
in reaching Allah There is no
way to reach Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala without having knowledge
of what pleases Allah and what
angers Allah. There is no way
to reach Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala without the guidance of
the messenger Muhammad
So, this is why he has
communicated to us the Quran is
sunnah. Merely a person doing
what he thinks or feels is
correct and will bring him
closer to Allah. This person is
living in illusions and
hallucinations. He's not living
in the real world In the real
world, what raises a person
with a law is knowledge and its
implementation. And what lowers
a person in the side of Allah
is ignorance and it's
implementation
and so, the next thing that Ibn
ul Kaim Rahim Allah mentions is
Notice the wording here He
said, that a person is
constantly remembering Allah in
each state that he is in and in
every place that he is in.
Notice the wording A person is
not only remembering Allah in
times of hardship Allah is not
a person is not only
remembering Allah in times of
ease. A person is not only
remembering Allah in the
Masjid, a person is not only
remembering Allah when he is in
fear, but a person is
remembering a law almost in a
vacuum, irrespective of his
circumstances. If he's in a
jail cell. He's remembering a
law and if he's on a throne,
he's remembering Allah. If he
is in the Masjid, he is
remembering a law and if he is
in the depths of, the depths of
the darkest places of the
earth. He is remembering Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. This is
one of the greatest things that
will cause a person to become
that will cause a person to
become truly guided by Allah.
and so a man came to the
prophet and he said
he said oh messenger of Allah,
the rulings and laws and
regulations of Islam have
become overwhelming to me. I
don't even know where to start
and I don't know how to
completely hold and and bear
this burden. that the prophet
said, after he was asked, for
the
[Silence]
thing that will will open that
up for me. One thing that if I
constantly do it and if I stick
to it and I'm dedicated to it,
the rest will fall into place.
He said, your tongue should
always be, should always be
enveloped and always be damp
with thee remembrance of Allah
What does the remembrance of
Allah mean? It means two
things. Remembrance of Allah is
three categories. As a as the
mention. Number one, you
remember him with your heart
and your tongue together.
Number two, you remember him
with your heart and not your
tongue. Number three, you
remember him with your tongue
and not your heart.
So, what does this mean? A
person is saying
Allah but his mind, his heart
is are somewhere else. This is
the lowest level. We have
another level where heart is
remembering Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. Meaning that a person
is contemplating Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala,
contemplating and remembering
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala but
his he is not remembering him
with his tongue. And we have a
third level which is the
highest level and that is
remembering Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala with both the tongue and
the heart. And he mentions that
people are two types. are some
that begin to remember Allah
with their tongue and their
heart is absent. but they
forced their heart to become
present because of their
diligence and tenacity in
remembering Allah with their
tongue. So, first, the tongue,
then the heart joins. And then
there are another type who
remember Allah with their heart
and then the tongue joins.
right? Obviously, the second is
superior to the first because
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala does
not judge you by your, by your
images or your bodies rather he
judges you by your, by your
hearts and your actions, the
prophet said. And he mentions
that, Allah looks to the heart.
This is what is important to
Allah. So what we are getting
at here is that constantly
remembering Allah in every kind
of in every kind of feeling or
emotion or situation a person
is in. Whether you are
comfortable or uncomfortable,
whether you are angry, or you
are happy, whether you are sad,
or you are at ease and
tranquil, Whatever the person's
state of being is they will
always remember Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. If you can, work
hard enough to make it equal no
matter what your situation is,
then this means that the person
has reached the height of amen
that is rarely reached by a
human being.
you can make it to where no
matter how angry you are or how
calm you are, you equally
remember Allah No matter how
sad you are or how comfortable
you are, you equally remember
Allah. No matter how,
no matter how, safe and
tranquil you feel, or no matter
how anxious you feel, you are
equally remember Allah, this
person has reached a height of
a man that is, rarely reached
by, most people.
Aware, no matter what the
remembrance of Allah is the
baseline of of his life. It is
the baseline of his life. No
matter what his circumstances,
his remembrance of Allah
remains the same. In public and
in private, in happiness, and
in sadness, in in in comfort,
and ease, or in discomfort and
hardship. The person constantly
remembering Allah. Likewise,
the place. Some people remember
Allah when they come to a place
where it sparks the remembrance
of Allah the Masjid.
Right? The Masjid. should spark
the remembrance of Allah in a
person. Because it is a place
where Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
is remembered. A man came to
the Masjid one day and he said,
oh Allah, forgive me and
Mohammed and don't forgive
anyone else along with us. Is
what he said. and then he went
to a corner of the Masjid and
he started urinating. For the
companions of all the Allah
were gearing up to take action
and the prophet said This
narration is in Muslim.
Leave him alone. Let him
finish. Let him finish
urinating. Yes, let him finish
Because if you drag him around
the Masjid now, he's going to
continue urinating and it's
going to be all over the
Masjid. So, yes, let him finish
it all in one place so that we
can have it so that we can have
it quarantined. I mean, he's
already started. He might as
well finish. So, they can be
only in one place. and so,
after he finished The prophet
called for a bucket of water to
be poured on the place where he
had urinated. And then he told
the man he called the man over
and he said, what did he say to
him? He said, in the us in the
Quran. He said these Masajids
[Silence]
appropriate in the Masjid is
the remembrance of Allah, the
recitation of the Quran, and
and things that are similar to
that. This is what the Masjid
is for Anything else that is
done in the Masjid falls into
two categories. It is either
impermissible or it is
something that is acceptable as
long as it does not lead to
something that is
impermissible. sleeping or
eating or something that.
Is it permissible to eat in the
Masjid? Yes. But what happens
if we let everybody eat in the
Masjid? Everybody comes here
and takes his lunch break and
brings him food and what's the
message going to start smelling
like? He's going to start
smelling a food court and
a mall, in a shopping mall,
right? That's not acceptable.
So, can we say we do cordially,
we would ask nobody to eat in
the Masjid. Yes, we could say
that. What about if we allow
everybody who's passing by to
come and bring his blanket and
pillow and just you know, kick
his feet up and sleep. The
Masjid may turn into what? May
turn into you know, a super aid
motel, right?
is this acceptable? No. This is
not what the Masjid was built
for. It's permissible but it
will lead to something that is
abusive. Therefore, we can say
cordially, we would ask people
not to sleep here, right? I
know that's not a thing here in
Chicago really but in places
New York City, that's a
big thing. Because people don't
have cars and they're traveling
all day on trains and stuff and
come through massage they take
naps and sleep and sometimes
sleep over and sleep through
the night and all of these
other things in the Masjid and
some Massage you go into the
entire floor is just full of
people sleeping, right? This is
not what the Masjid was. Built
for, designed for. So, people
come in and they sleep and they
have bed bugs and they have
foul smell and they have
whatever and some of them come
and sleep and they don't even
pray. Time for prayer come the
event is called, they don't get
up, they keep sleeping,
etcetera, etcetera. What
happens? The Masjid now has is
being abused, right? So,
there's a difference between
that which is permissible and
that which is abusive. So, No
matter where a person is, they
remember Allah. The Masjid is
supposed to spark deep,
intimate emotions of
remembrance of Allah. Subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
emotions of remembrance of
Allah. Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
That as soon as you see the
Masjid, you remember Allah. And
in your darkest times, you
remember thee, light and
texture, and place of the
Masjid. This is your place of
solace. This is what the Masjid
is supposed to represent. But
if we fill the Masjid with back
biting and talking and food and
you know, rudeness and clicks
and all these other things that
happen in some Massaged. What
happens, that goes away. The
remembrance of Allah fades and
the remembrance of the duniya
begins to intensify. The
prophet said that the closest
places on earth to Allah are
the and the furthest of places
from Allah on the earth are the
marketplaces. We know this
narration. And so, because of
this, it is impermissible for a
person to buy or sell inside of
the Masjid, right? Now, the
scholars differ on on whether
or not that is if that is
something which is permissible
for the sake of the Masjid. So,
for example here, we may buy or
sell books and things that
which are Islamic books in the
Masjid but this is for the
benefit of the Masjid and it
aids in the remembrance of
Allah Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
That's a different situation
but if a person wants to sell
tomatoes or tires or cars or
things that in the Masjid.
The scholars have agreed that
this is something impermissible
for the most part.
why is that? Because if we
allow the worst place,
the furthest place from Allah
to merge with the closest
places to Allah and we allow
them to mix together and merge
together. Where now are we
supposed to go to be close to
Allah Where? Where where is our
calf? Where is our haven? Does
it, we don't have it anymore
right? So, we have to keep
these as separate as possible
just as we have to keep genders
as separate as possible. Just
as we have to keep good and
evil as separate as possible
and the people of good and the
people of evil as separate as
possible, etcetera, etceter
right? So, remembering Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala in any in
any set of circumstances in any
place. So, you do not only
remember Allah when you come to
the Masjid but you remember
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
outside of the Masjid. Perhaps
even more intensely outside of
the Masjid because you feel a a
feeling of distance from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala when you
are not in the Masjid. This is
one of the greatest things that
will be a cause for a person's
heart to be open to the light
and guidance of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. This will be one of
the greatest things that will
open a person's heart to the
guidance and light of Allah.
Subhan Allah
So, constantly remembering
Allah. We don't just mean that
a person is constantly saying
or reciting the Quran. This of
course is outward and clear and
blatant remembrance of Allah.
But what is meant here is a
deeper meaning and that is not
only are we remembering Allah
with our tongues but we are in
constant contemplation of the
of the remembrance of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Whenever a
person goes to make a decision,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is
the first thing that comes to
mind. Whenever a person says
something, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala's pleasure or anger are
the first things that come to
mind. Whenever a person goes to
go somewhere or be somewhere or
do something or commit to
something or make a decision or
any of the things they are
remembering Allah how in their
in their mind, the first thing
that comes to their mind is, is
this something that pleases
Allah or is this something that
may anger Allah who
He says, number six,
he says the sixth thing that is
of the greatest causes for a
person to be guided and they're
hard to be open to thee, to
thee, light and guidance of
Allah is being good to the
creation of Allah and
benefiting the creation of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in
any way that he can. Whether
that be with wealth, or with a
person's reputation, or with a
person own body. What does that
mean? Well, let's break that
down. When you are good to
Allah's creation, Allah will be
good to you. We see this
pattern all through the Quran
and all through the Sunnah.
That when a person shows mercy
to the creation, Allah will
show mercy to him. The
narration, very popular, famous
narration that most of us know.
The merciful, the most
merciful, will show them mercy.
Show mer to those who are on
the earth and the one in the
heavens will show mercy to you.
This is what the prophet said.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
tell them that they
forgive and pardon? Do you all
not desire that Allah forgive
you? So, we understand from
this that if you forgive
others, Allah will forgive you.
If you show mercy to others,
Allah will show mercy to you.
If you are kind to others,
Allah will be kind to you. And
the narration of in Muslim,
Allah Abdi, Abdul for Akihi,
the Allah is at the service of
his servant. Allah will always
be at the aid of his servant as
long as his servant is at the
aid of his brother. As long as
you are helping others, Allah
will always be helping you.
Right? As long as you are
merciful to others, Allah will
be merciful to you. As long as
you pardon others, Allah will
pardon you. As long as you are,
helpful to others, Allah will
be helpful to you. Etcetera,
etcetera. As long as you
conceal people's mistakes,
Allah will conceal your
mistakes. As long as you
overlook other people's
shortcomings, Allah will
overlook your shortcomings,
etcetera. To the point that
this is almost a rough estimate
of what you should expect on
the day of resurrection. If you
wish to see how is Allah going
to treat me and deal with me on
the day of judgement? It's a
question we should all ask
ourselves by the way. And it's
a ques that we should all ask
ourselves every single day When
you wake up in the morning and
when you go to sleep at night,
when you wake up in the
morning, you are to look in the
mirror and you are to say,
today, is going to be the best
day, the day that I try my
hardest. Okay? And you should
say, based on my intention and
my actions today, this will
dictate how Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala is going to treat me.
When you stand in front of the
mirror, in the morning, you
should imagine yourself
standing in front of Allah.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
is going to happen
Prophet said, there is not one
of you except that he will
stand before Allah and Allah
will speak to him. There will
be no translator or
intermediary between the two.
You're going to stand in front
of Allah. Can you imagine?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
describe the day of
resurrection as Yo Mahalim.
He described the day of
resurrection as a great and
tremendous day. A day when the
people will all rise for the
Lord of the worlds. Can you
imagine yourself How frail is
the human being?
How frail are we, huh? How
frail is the human being? If it
gets just a little bit cold,
that's it. You can't sleep, you
can't sit, your joints hurt,
you can't do anything. If it
gets just a little bit too hot,
you sweat, you take your
clothes off, you can't sleep,
you can't eat, you can't human
being is extremely, extremely
frail.
This frail human being who is
filled with many different
emotions that fight each other.
human being is naturally
ignorant, is naturally selfish,
is naturally ungrateful as
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
described the human being.
is naturally oppressive. In
spite of himself being so weak.
Now, imagine your weakness
and imagine that weakness
standing in front of the King
of Kings, the judge of judges,
Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala.
This is something that's going
to happen As a matter of fact,
it is so sure that it's going
to happen, that Allah speaks
about it in the Quran as if
it's already happened.
Well our Torah is
the
[Silence]
as well. It is so sure that it
might as well have already
happened. It is so positively
going to happen that it can
referred to as past tense.
That's how positive we are that
we're going to stand in front
of Allah. With all our
weaknesses and with all our
skeletons and sins. and then
you're going to stand in front
of Allah Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
You can't hide anything. You
can't argue. He is very swift
in judgement. Right?
and so, if you want to know
roughly When that day comes
when I stand in front of Allah
with all my weakness and all of
my sins, how is Allah going to
treat me? Look at how you treat
other people. Look at how you
treat the creation of Allah.
greet the creation of Allah and
other people Well, you can
expect nothing less from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. And if you
are angry and arrogant and
dismissive and etcetera, then
you can expect something of
similar nature from Allah
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. We will
end with that for tonight to
allow Allah Muhammad